♪ ♪
>> Tucker: PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN
VIRGINIA, LIKE SO MANY SCHOOLS
IN THIS COUNTRY HAVE GONE INSANE
IN THE LAST YEAR.
INSTEAD, THEY ARE INDOCTRINATING
CHILDREN.
SCARY.
IN LATIN COUNTY, KIDS ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO READ "TO KILL A
MOCKINGBIRD" ANYMORE.
INSTEAD, THEY ARE ASSIGNED
NOVELS -- GO PARENTS HAVE BEEN
REVOLTING AGAINST US, NOT JUST
RIGHT-WINGERS.
NOT JUST POLITICALLY ACTIVE
PEOPLE.
PEOPLE WITH KIDS IN THE SCHOOLS.
WHY WOULD YOU WANT YOUR KIDS
TAUGHT SOME BIZARRE POISONOUS
RACIAL THEORY?
IT'S DISGUSTING.
SO, LAST NIGHT THE SCHOOL BOARD
MET AND AGREED TO SOLICIT PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
THEY DIDN'T TAKE THAT MANY, BUT
THOSE THEY HEARD WEREN'T VERY
POSITIVE.
>> THE WESTERN CULTURE, THE
FOUNDING DOCUMENTS ARE BEING
CALLED EVIL AND RACIST.
>> YOU ARE NOT THE CAPTAIN.
WE ARE YOUR BOSSES AND GOD
WILLING WE WERE RETURN MOST OF
YOU TO THE PRIVATE SECTOR VERY
SOON.
>> I'M REMINDED OF THE TYRANNY
OF COMMUNIST CHINA WHERE YOUR
MONEY IS STOLEN AND USED IN
GOVERNMENT SCHOOLS.
NOT PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THESE ARE GOVERNMENT SCHOOLS,
LIKE HERE, TO INDOCTRINATE
CHILDREN AGAINST THEIR PARENTS.
>> AS LONG AS YOU MARXISTS PUSH
YOUR AGENDA ON MY CHILD, SHE
WILL NOT BE RETURNING.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: SO THE SCHOOL BOARD
DIDN'T WANT TO HEAR IT.
THEY ARE AS OUT OF TOUCH AS MOST
OF OUR INSTITUTIONS.
DIDN'T WANT TO HEAR IT.
THEY HAD IT DECLARED AN UNLAWFUL
ASSEMBLY.
ONE PARENT WAS ARRESTED.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE COUNTY TAX PAYER PAYS
YOUR SALARY!
>> YOU GUYS ARE ACTUALLY
SUPPORTING THE SUPPRESSION OF
PEOPLE'S RIGHTS.
>> DEPUTIES, PLEASE ARREST THIS
INDIVIDUAL FOR TRESPASSING.
>> Tucker: SO THEY HANDCUFFED
HIM AND DRAGGED HIM AWAY.
DIDN'T WANT TO HEAR FROM HIM
APPARENTLY.
JOHN JOINS US TO EXPAND WHAT
HAPPENED.
JOHN, THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
IT FEELS LIKE THIS IS THE MOMENT
WHERE PEOPLE HAVE FINALLY HAD IT
WITH THIS SCARY RACIAL THEORY.
TELL US WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU.
WHY DID THEY ARREST YOU?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION,
TUCKER.
BECAUSE AS BEST I UNDERSTAND IT,
I WAS IN A PLACE WHERE
FREE SPEECH HAS TO HAPPEN.
IF YOU WANT TO REDRESS YOUR
GRIEVANCES ABOUT A SCHOOL BOARD,
THERE IS NO OTHER PLACE YOU CAN
DO IT THAN IN A SCHOOL BOARD
MEETING.
IN THIS CASE, WENT ONTO PUBLIC
LAND, WENT INTO A PUBLIC
AUDITORIUM.
THEREFORE A PUBLIC FORUM THAT WE
WERE INVITED TO AND I WAS SIGNED
UP TO GIVE PUBLIC COMMENTS.
AND AT THE END OF ALL THAT,
EVERY SINGLE PERSON THERE, ALL
500 PARENTS HAVE THEIR
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS TRAMPLED
ON BY THE SCHOOL BOARD AND ITS
SUPERINTENDENT.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE GOING TO
GET A REVOLUTION.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
IGNORE LEGITIMATE COMPLAINTS.
PEOPLE GET RADICAL.
I HOPE IT DOESN'T HAPPEN, BUT
YOU SEE HOW IT COULD.
SO IN THIS CASE, THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO PAY THE LATIN COUNTY
SCHOOLS.
THE BUILDING WAS RESERVED AND
OPEN UNTIL 7:00 P.M.
THEY ARRESTED YOU BEFORE SEVEN
AS I UNDERSTAND.
>> YEAH, ACTUALLY WAS CLOSER TO
ABOUT 545.
AND WE WERE SUPPOSED TO GO UNTIL
7:00 P.M.
UNTIL THE SCHOOL BOARD HEARD
SOMETHING THEY DIDN'T LIKE,
WHICH WAS IRONICALLY APPLAUSE
FOR ONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT WE
WERE SUPPORTING, SENATOR BLACK.
THEY SHUT IT DOWN.
BUT THERE WAS NOT VIOLENCE.
IT WASN'T ANYTHING CRAZY GOING
ON.
PEOPLE STAYED THERE.
THEY ACTUALLY STARTED SINGING
AND THEN WE JUST ENCOURAGED
FOLKS THAT IF THE SCHOOL BOARD
DIDN'T WANT TO HEAR IT, WE WERE
GOING TO HEAR FROM ONE ANOTHER.
AND WE ALLOWED A VERY ORDERLY
PEACEFUL PROCESS OF ALLOWING
PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY START
SPEAKING.
AND THEY DID THAT.
THEY LINED UP AND STARTED
PRESENTING THEIR PERSPECTIVES.
AND WE ALLOW THE OTHER SIDE TO
DO THE SAME.
AND THEN SUDDENLY, IT WAS
DECLARED AN UNLAWFUL ASSEMBLY
AFTER THE THING THAT YOU ARE
SHOWING RIGHT NOW.
AS BEST AS I CAN TELL, IT WAS A
COMPLETE LEFTIST TACTIC THAT WAS
PREPLANNED BECAUSE NO ONE THAT
WAS LINED UP TO SPEAK WAS
INVOLVED IN ANY OF THAT.
SO, THE RESULT WAS THEY DECLARED
AN UNLAWFUL ASSEMBLY AND THEN
THEY MOVED A WHOLE SERIES OF
DEPUTIES AND TRIED TO PUSH THEM
OUT OF THE ROOM THREATENING THEM
WITH ARREST.
>> Tucker: SO THEY DIDN'T LIKE
WHAT YOU HAD TO SAY SO THEY
DECLARED YOU'RE TALKING ILLEGAL
AND THEN GOT THE COPS WHO SHOULD
BE ASHAMED OF THEMSELVES TO
ARREST YOU FOR SAYING SOMETHING
THAT THE SCHOOL BOARD DIDN'T
LIKE.
>> THAT'S CORRECT PARENTS BUT
WHEN AM I MISSING ANYTHING?
>> NO, THAT IS WHAT IS SO
INFERIOR RATING.
THERE IS SUCH A HIGH STANDARD
FOR FREE SPEECH.
IT IS THE MOST SACRED OF ALL OF
OUR RIGHTS AND IT TAKES AN
AMAZING AMOUNT OF JUSTIFICATION
TO SHUT DOWN FREE SPEECH.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
IT DOES.
NOT LIKING IT DOES NOT ADDED
JUSTIFICATION.
I THINK ONLY UNTIL PEOPLE ARE
WILLING TO BE ARRESTED FOR
EXERCISING THEIR CONSTIT